now  i'll relive my 20s a big return to las  vegas nightlife is here ghost bar palms  held its grand opening last night it's  reopening so it first debuted all the  way back in 2001 remember it was just so  popular  it has been closed though since 2017.  now the new owners of the pumps bringing  it back to life resurrecting it if you  will our las vegas now team was there  for the first toast last night so there  you're gonna see some really incredible  views because of how high up it is it's  like the 55th floor there's the views  and i believe they're going to have live  music kind of jazz music as well and  ghost created cocktails your 20s  that was reliving your 20s um so that  was what yesterday  oh are they walking around with upside  down chandeliers on their heads  yes vegas okay so that's how it happens